just check out this position before the  end of the first time control yes panko  was literally dominating the position  here with roo g8 with a very powerful  pawn on a7 and just take it on c4 and  that's it taking on c4  these pawns on c6 and a6 are weaknesses  now you play something like d5 simply go  queen of four king h2 a lot of easy  moves and the pawn on e7 still remains  but it was the nerves it was the nerves  and he went for the through g3 missed it  traded the rocks and the queen end game  was very very tricky  it was very tricky but it's not easy to  switch this mindset he was uh fighting  there for an attack  right he was looking all at all these  ideas with rook g3 and  it's not easy to switch to just taking  pawns and playing against the weaknesses  on the queen side  right  well draw it's official hikaru nakamura  yes  he qualifies for the semi-final